hello I wanted to make a special video
today talking about the rates of
learning the learning rates as far as
languages are concerned but not only
languages well insofar as languages are
concerned you can we can distinguish we
can generally distinguish three phases
and this is a common commonly accepted
fact
Guilhem a three phase the intermediate
phase and the advanced phase um right
now I just wrote I just I've drawn this
special special graph here
I just bought a blackboard I thought it
was like a very good idea to have it
aboard and we can distinguish three
phases as I said the commonly accepted
phases and I actually kind of agree
about this and you can you can you can
tell the difference between you can you
can say that you can tell if there is a
learning rate it means that this is the
efficiency of your learning process
in the elementary face yo Metro face is
has a few features the your learning
rate is low and means that it is not
quite efficient and this is obvious
because from a scientific point of view
one can argue that the problem that
consists of the fact that nuance
interactions between words and axes are
not activated it means that we're still
building a net here we're just trying to
figure out how things sound in the
language they're quite you know weird
sounds so our brain keys were used a
different sound and grammatical
structures and words themselves
specially limbs were very very different
from ours for example Arabic for Chinese
and other difficult languages in the
intermediate phase things start to get
slightly better but the learning rate is
too low and low we have two results I
can distinguish and
this zone and this our developer zone
it's like low intermediate and high
intermediate and at this point we start
figuring out a lot of things at the
language which is the the cold
intermediate phase but still we're not
fluent yet it's so called fluency I call
this phase deliberate learning
deliberate learning means that in this
face and I will discuss this in the next
videos each for every faith we're doing
we're learning deliberately we're using
books using language grammars we're
using a simal or using teach yourself
you're using things to get accustom of
language they're guiding us because
they're our authors who wrote who just
established patterns for us and we're
just following them we're not autonomous
there comes a point here which is called
epiphany point in literature where a
kind of a linguistic explosion happens
and you find yourself autonomous it
means that you have accumulated a lot of
knowledge and at this point in this
precise point things start getting very
easy we don't know why but that's that's
the way it happens it means that we have
learnt we spent hours and hours trying
to figure out how the language works in
the elementary phase and an intermediate
phase I don't know how long this will
take but it will take a little bit and
depends on how much time and how much
energy in above all how you learn so
this point which is called the epiphany
point and we could pass this point we
could call themselves fluent in a way
according to my vision at least this is
called a deliberate learning as I said
it's phase one if they stew and when
you're linguistically autonomous means
that you're you find yourself in the
advanced space this doesn't mean that
you stop learning we never stop learning
for the thing is that passed this point
we're autonomous it means that we find
for example I'll let us consider Chinese
you find a word you just figured out a
lot of characters how they work and how
they sound and what they mean and you
find other characters you put them
and you understand the meaning without
consulting anyone Cavallari doesn't
school it's not just a small example to
make you understand what I mean by
autonomy and and at this point the rate
of learning is almost vertical it's it's
exponential because you learn things at
a faster age you talk to foreigners you
can retain words that you didn't retain
before at this point people were like
frustrated sent me messages and is eight
why can I just recall things this is the
argument of this will be the subject of
another video which is which will have
to do with memory and you'll find quite
some some some surprises a few surprises
there it's all saying in general this is
a graph through recap this is a graph
that explains the learning rate and the
time and the efficiency learning rate
comes as the efficiency of learning and
acquiring the language there are three
main phases the two main phases are
deliberate learning the the two first
phases which is the first low mentoree
and intermediate and the the reason why
a lot of people develops because the
rate is slow the efficiency of learning
is a little bit low but depending on how
much time you dedicate to a language and
how you do it this is very important
it's not just a matter of learning of
reading and listening and I will explain
this in another video - you will get to
this point which is called the epiphany
point and at this point when you start
talking to foreigners or reading books
all you have to do is keeping a language
of life and expanding it you will do it
much more easily than you need ever done
before and this is called linguistic
autonomy so I will discuss the things
this is just just a general description
of the whole process and the next videos
will discuss what you should do here
here and here so thank you so much for
listening to me and we will talk and
we'll meet up in the next videos bye